okay I've told you before about the
evangelical support for Israel being
very heavily driven by the belief that
by supporting Israel the second coming
of Jesus Christ will happen and
depending on your flavor of Christianity
this will bring about the rapture or the
apocalypse or the end times or the end
of the world
whichever lovely phrase your sect
attributes to that event I've also told
you before about outrageous Fox News
host Jeanine Pirro who was at some point
a judge somewhere really scary to think
about and she combined her insanity with
the evangelical insanity around Israel
in one lovely segment where she praised
Donald Trump's decision to move the
embassy that the United States has in
Israel from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem as the
fulfillment of a Biblical prophecy
listen to Jeanine Pirro here just
gushing about how great Donald Trump is
Donald Trump's and Iranians who are the
descendants of Persia a message to
reflect on their own history right and
that it was the king of Persia who a
thousand years before Mohammed was even
born
that said Jerusalem was the capital of
the Jewish people's country Russia
there will be no Ottoman empires or
chien nations that will destroy
Jerusalem any longer Donald Trump
recognized history he like King Cyrus
before him fulfilled the Biblical
prophecy
the gods worshipped by Jews Christians
and yes yes Muslims that Jerusalem is
the eternal capital of the Jewish state
and that the Jewish people finally
deserve a righteous free and sovereign
Israel I noticed she has that same weird
pronunciation of Jerusalem that Trump
had in that video where it didn't it
wasn't clear whether he was trying to
eat his tongue or maybe had a denture
issue I wonder if maybe it's like having
veneers that are too big or something
like that
crucial it's a weird did you notice that
Pat it's a weird thing that's going on
he it's connected to being a Trump
supporter in some way would be hard to
draw that line yeah hard to parse it out
how is this news like how does this
count as news and now
these are quite literally the rantings
of a disjointed and ignorant person and
I wonder like do they know that this is
the biblical prophecy that ends with the
destruction of life or the rapture I
know some of them know that and love it
like they think that's just that's the
greatest thing nothing better than the
rapture but I think that that's part of
the story that some of these people are
missing and and the other just laughable
thing that shows you how transparently
devoid of any meaning all of this
nonsense is is that in reality the
relocation of an embassy doesn't have
anything to do with Biblical prophecy
right like Jerusalem as the real and
enduring capital of Israel either is or
is not but a nearly obese 71 year old
president saying that we're moving a
building from one city to another that
doesn't materially change the biblical
meaning of what's going on and that's
what sort of truly beneath evangelical
support for Israel it's this nonsense
we're more than 50% of American
evangelical Christians believe literally
that Israel is a requirement for the
rapture or Armageddon or the apocalypse
call it what you want the end of the
world they want that right and they see
Jerusalem is ground zero for that and it
is really important to understand this
when you hear about the political
support that Israel gets from the right
which is by the way the same place where
a lot of anti-semitism exists as well
which is an interesting thing they don't
like Israel for the Jews or for the
great weather and beaches or for the
food of Tel Aviv they believe that
Israel will lead to the fulfillment of
their religious prophecy and these are
the same types who believe that the
Bible predicted 9/11 this is a death
cult of the most extreme proportions and
of course like every Biblical prophecy
nothing will happen
right these people won't be around to
see it they'll just say well it's gonna
happen at some point after I'm no longer
alive and it is vilde that this counts
as a news report on Fox News truly yeah
yeah and does judge Jeanine really think
that Trump is sitting around at the
White House eating his junk food
watching Fox News and he thinks you know
what I'm going to
and here's to thousands of years of
Persian history I'm gonna be just like
King Cyrus that's not the president that
we know and love yeah certainly it's not
what he's thinking but regardless they
still see him as a guy who is somehow I
guess fulfilling the prophecy and it's
it's deranged and it's depraved and
apparently on Fox News it counts as
reasonable news commentary which is the
scariest thing of all the video you just
watched was made possible by support
from you please go to patreon.com slash
david pakman show you can make a pledge
of as little as $1 per month and every
dollar helps to support the work that
we're doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad